oh you look cool as hell thank you
you're so cool oh my God how's your New
Year going good really really good yeah
yeah well last time we talked about you
don't make resolutions you make like
dream lists right do okay do you have
those yet do you a couple of them um but
I tend to try and keep them to myself so
I I tick them off as they go but one of
them is to finish my album so I've been
working on that oh do that for me please
I'm on it I promise specifically
selfishly yes like I've got like things
that I really want to do and travel and
places that I want to go to so it's all
of that yeah I love it first you were
like I don't really like to tell people
and I was like is that about
accountability well yeah because it's
also like well you know I I want people
like I make these lists and I keep them
to myself and there's they're like a
secret checklist for myself yeah I don't
necessarily need accountability but I go
CU I keep going back to them to read
them to make sure that I have it but
there's this weird sort of like if I
tell people maybe it won't come true
thing oh a little superstitious I'm like
that too yeah um so so we're celebrating
music's connection to civil rights so
who were your social musical
Inspirations uh Nina Simone and AR artha
Frank oh yeah good so so yeah and what i
is there like you the to yeah yeah what
I found out actually um whilst I was
learning about both of them because I I
sing them a lot I sing their music a lot
is that uh artha was uh inspired by Nina
Simone uh and she ended up doing a
couple of the songs that Nina Simone had
on on her albums young gifted in black
and you know and uh and obviously Nina
was very much in the the Civil Rights
Movement her music was about that at
some point and they sort of met in the
middle and both of those women are huge
Inspirations for me yeah definitely it's
interesting because nobody thinks about
it but one what was like the first time
you heard artha like I think I question
I want to say I was maybe 10 years old
okay in my mother's car on the way to
school and I think it was chain of Falls
yeah I think mine was was around 13 and
it was it was respect or chain of FS one
of I can't remember which one but I just
there was something different about her
voice is it just like it just sort of
like hits you like in the right in the
Solar like just breaks you yeah and the
tone but nobody really talks about this
but she actually did Cover quite a bit
of music like that was a lot of her
career which nobody really talk I feel
like that's maybe what influenced me to
do like covers all the time because I
love it so much and I love she had this
wonderful magical way of making any song
you may have heard that belonged to
someone else sound like it was already
written for her they were just a
stepping stone to get to her so when I
was a kid I would listen and I was like
oh I love her so they're like well you
know she that's a cover like they did
that originally I like wait what a cover
I was like that's what I'm saying I
never knew like all those I ended up
finding that out and I was like I didn't
oh didn't it gosh she yeah Special
nobody wanted her to cover the song oh
no oh no cuz then it was G it was not
yours anymore but do you do you hear
from Young fans like who've inspired you
as they inspired you who young fans who
inspired yeah like how Nina and artha
inspired you you hear of young me
inspiring that yeah absolutely what I
mean I I hear it I I do hear it and it
always um it always is a little bit
overwhelming because I feel like I've
just begun you know what I mean I feel
like I I still have much to give and and
hopefully more to learn as well yeah but
you're already so incredible literally
like in my iners we saying
together I've
never you have a Flawless transition
voice like you're like you transition to
every different Octave of your voice
flawlessly thank you it was intimidating
as hell to sing on now it is just one of
my favorite things I've ever done but
just to hear you in my in ears is a
blessing you are so saying that yeah
well inredible I mean that your voice is
astounding and I know you're not lying
because you don't have to I would not
say it yeah and you are I literally was
I think Jesse I talk I was like well
that's what a singer sounds like yeah I
was like wow well speaking of fans so we
came across this video of Cynthia
singing on the street so let's see it
and hear
[Music]
it I'll
be my
Dr
I'm so good funny girl obviously I love
funny girl so that's the you're I love
that whole musical but what happened
there how did you just start singing
that I love you well um he
you're just like you know what I think I
in the middle of the street I bumped
into in the middle of the street and and
he asked me to to sing something I think
he must have heard me sing it one time
before and he was like would you can you
just do a little bit of it can you just
and so I was like okay sure I don't mind
any opportunity where I could make some
music that's what I'm going to do oh I
don't either yeah people always that's
like people come up to me be like oh I
don't know if you want me to talk about
American I'm like hell yeah dude that's
like why here yeah it's also like there
just you're going to care when they
don't want you to sing that's the thing
I think I think the wonderful thing
about that I knew it would bring him
such joy and he's such a joyous energy
and I day it was so awesome and I was
having a great time and people across
the street could see it like it was just
fun and you're reminded right of like
why you do why you do how you fell in
love with it yeah those are important
moments our new film is called gri you
can see it in theaters Nationwide
February 16 today we are celebrating
social movements that music has touched
or inspired so even in our personal
lives we use music to set the tone for
whatever kind of mood we're in or
whatever's going on our Liv so what's on
your like latest playlist like what's
inspiring you latest playlist um oh
there's a song by a new artist called
Manana and it's called um you first and
it's oh that's I like the title oh it's
it's brilliant it it is about I guess
they this is a couple that might have
broken up and he he says I'll do this if
you do that first so I I'll I'll I'll
stop saying I'll stop St joking cuz you
don't like my jokes but you you stop
first or I'll I'll smile for you who's
going to make the move first and I think
it's one of the most beautiful songs
I've ever heard oh my gosh um again the
new movie is called Drift so kind of
tell us what it's about who's your
character so this uh it's about a young
lady called Jacqueline who uh is
displaced because of the war in Liberia
and she finds herself alone in Greece um
and she's you follow her just trying to
put the pieces of her life back together
um you know it's tough for her but she
tries to make every day uh the next day
and um she meets a a tour guide who is
sort of in her own way also trying to
put her life back together and with they
find friendship within each other um and
something in the other person breaks
Jacqueline open and she finally can
begin to heal yeah I love that cuz it
also expresses like the seasons of
friendships and people that come in and
out of your life and I I feel like
people come in and out for reasons yeah
ah well here's the thing it would be is
the song that you um you and who wrote
it with you Laura and vula we coot oh my
gosh I was telling her in the break I
was sent this song while I was out in
New York just running errands and doing
stuff and I teared up I CED I was like
this is one of the best songs I've heard
in a very long time like it is so
beautiful it's the production is so
beautiful sparse the vocal ability you
are crazy rude like crazy rude it's just
insane how fluid it is I've never heard
anything like it it's the messaging is
so great and you lift it up you know you
don't hide it with a much you just lift
up the actual purpose of the song like
what was that like the songwriting
process for that I I was really moved by
the whole thing just because Laura is is
such a wonderful friend I think she's
unbelievably talented and I it happened
because I was on a run whilst we were
shooting the movie and I make playlists
for for the movies that I do or the TV
shows that whatever just so that I can
find myself in this the space and I put
one of her songs on my playlist called
father and as it was playing it felt
like it was the language of the piece it
felt like it spoke the language of the
piece and I was like oh my goodness I
think I want to write the song for this
and I want to do it with this person so
I I text Laura and I was like would you
please would you please do this song
with me and I sent her the material I
sent her um the the like clips of the
film and I sent her the script and uh
she said yes so we then took a couple of
nights and went away and wrote together
and we vocal it in in a couple days and
that's what that's what came of it and
it she just was I guess she said she was
inspired by the water in the piece and
the story and she just got it and I was
Bo did do yeah it was I I literally
listened and I was like
I felt like I'd never written a song
before I was like I was like what am I
doing with my life I was like oh my God
and I love that by the way I love that
like when you're inspired and challenged
by other artists it's amazing I my dream
is for you to be seeing this on the
Oscars like you're going to need some
other singers because there's a lot of
vocalists um go and thank you for saying
that oh my goodness I'm on a campaign
I'm on a
campaign come on Oscar people whoever
you are I want all I want to do is
introduce it that's all I want to do is
introduce her on stage and just be
present while it's happening it's it's
so good and I I have to say this too
because was your mom did she help you
with the character and drift so yeah uh
when I my mom and I have spoken about
some of her experiences uh in her Youth
and when she was about 15 16 she was um
fleeing in the thefran war in Nigeria so
she wasz child of war and she managed to
make it out and she was also a able to
get back home but uh she told me some of
her experience es about what it was like
when she when they couldn't find food
and when they were having to try and
find look find safety and all of those
things and she's been through it so um
just having her mom in her life it's not
like you're watching a movie She Made it
she's here which is what a superhero
yeah yeah she to her sisters and
everything so she had younger sisters
with her too man what a rad mom yeah
she's pretty cool so proud Edith man
once again just killing it for the human
race just you know yeah asked me for an
iPad she really I owe her more than
iPads that's for sure yeah but the
iPad's cool cuz she's a mom she wants
you to FaceTime her on it yeah and and
Candy Crush yeah oh not I like him yeah
gra to select New York theaters February
9th and opens Nationwide February 16th
and look for Cynthia's new song from the
film it's called it would
[Music]
be
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home